[Musica]
i cani che va da benvenuti nuovissimo
video come potete notare abbiamo fatto
un intro fantastica che spero mi sia
piaciuta e soprattutto siamo in una
veste particolare non so se notate
questo maglione giorgi per favore
avviciniamoci cioè quanto è fantastico
io ovviamente sono dopo natale marina e
lui è il mio amato folletto giorgi poi
abbiamo mariah carrey qui ed anche
andrea salemme e qui abbiamo il nostro
fantastico credo che già conoscete che
girerà questo meraviglioso video ma mi
stavo dimenticando l'ospite fondamentale
di questo video pino un applauso peppino
caso poi anche il brano che è
soprattutto un po il nostro gioco che ci
accompagnerà in questa avventura
facciamo un primo piano di un perfetto
rimettiamo la detto ok quindi iniziamo
subito con l'albero dei marine allora
iniziamo subito con le luci visto che
l'anno scorso avete criticato perché ho
fatto un albero un po così insomma come
veniva vi lascio qui sopra il link del
video dell'anno scorso così poi vedrete
quanti progressi ho fatto quest'anno
perché questa iniziamo proprio delle
luci che la prima cosa che si mette
sull'albero
semplici andrè non per questo deve fare
ai ragazzi non vorrei finire il video è
pronto soccorso allora questa è la mia
idea non mi piaceva l'idea di girare
intorno all'albero separate leccese la
rimaste la perché io sono stato capito
tutto se no il team tutte le bugie le
metti e no e io giorgi li sistemiamo fi
non deve rimanere qua e magari con la
sposa bianco
prendiamo come front azione venire
questa è la rotazione con la moglie non
ci sono state avete visto che
sincronizzati e george se siamo avete
visto che sincronizzati e george però
devo dire che abbiamo fatto un grande
lavoro approviamo abbiamo già approviamo
ragazzi poi tutti i cavi a vista per
uccidere colma di giorgio
dallo stiramento
allora le lucine ci sono facciamo delle
apriamoci perfetto quindi dobbiamo
iniziare a posizionare le nostre colline
iniziamo da il colore allora l'anno
scorso aveva utilizzato il bianco e
argento che continuano ad esserci
quest'anno ma con un'aggiunta come dire
molto molto marina ovviamente date dei
tubi nessuna padre ormai mi basta così
[Musica]
adesso quale facciamo
ma anche dei casi fa male così che penso
e poi mettiamo queste quindi al 100 da
qui tra l'altro pietro magari mettiamo
le due valli non ci capita se non
vogliamo finire nel 2024 andrè dovrei
avere la stessa celerità di me giorgi
allora io vorrei soltanto farvi notare
la bellezza di come possiamo chiamarli
non so neanche balocchi sono sul tipo di
figli tuoi figli sono pozioni magiche
polvere di stelle e di fatah questa
volta quanto visionarle ragazzi ma
dentro c'è scritto tutto descritto
appennino la mia madrina
questa è la metterei qui provo rabbia
causa da queste basi roma polverini fa
d'avalos persa per sempre prima della
parata colore aziende regola come uno
degli altri natale le palline vecchie e
si sono già viste mettete dietro casa
allora questo mettiamolo qui siamo
scoppiati uno davanti all'altro di
ragazzi si mette lasciamo l'albero mi
voglio fare qualche domanda tipo qual è
la vostra ranzani natale preferita la
mia
[Musica]
[Applauso]
marina ma tu cosa fai a natale io a
natale non ho ancora deciso e non ho
ancora deciso cosa farci a capodanno e
lo deciderò forse qualche giorno prima
si è sfiorata la tragedia
portava per lasciarci panettone pandoro
ci ho preferito correntoni pandora dire
io lo capisco come la gente possa amare
qualche qualsiasi tipo di dolce con the
tree canditi c'è a chi piace incalliti
ma che cosa così ma che cosa hanno di
buoni del mondo dicitura il panettone di
milano ragazze io ma io sono fan del fan
in oro dopo quello quello che i regali
li aprite il 25 mattina con il 24 sera
solo i familiari di sangue di matera a
mezzanotte per il semplice motivo che ho
sempre fatto così
cavani ha di solito li aprivo giorni
prima perché spiego questo mi avevano
regalato quindi poi l'undici dicembre ho
imparato che non si fa venire apriamo a
natale che io non mi faccio ancora
mettere i regali sotto l'albero vado a
dormire prima tordino questo belli male
certo gli uomini il fratello di ugo
guarda identici bellissimo dove lo
mettiamo
lo guarda che la barba tu la puoi
spargere tipo un po medusa
no un po medusa ragazzi lasciano lo
spazio per le palline le new entry che
devo ancora far vedere che sono
meravigliose e lo so che i marinai si
laveranno
mi è arrivato qua spero all'albero qua
ci sono 18 palline vuol i ragazzi
maganetti la pdm dai solo quelle
glitterate veramente ragazzi è
un'esperienza sensoriale entrare
direttamente nell'albero se il treno per
pagarle proprio ci mancava un gatto su
questo albero ma dopo le avevamo detto
che le grosse informerò questa è una
media misura e allora same e metà
abbiamo questi qui ho fatti più gross
che poi abbiamo questi piccolini sia
lucidi e opachi quindi andiamo subito a
inserirlo questa l'abbiamo ancora
presentata e tula già la metti musica
questa è una delle più belle che ho
preso ieri punizione chiusa preso ieri
guardate la perfezione di questa pallina
descrivi c'è la bella una mongolfiera di
felicità va la questa come fa palline
una casa ma ora che bella che allora
arrivato il momento dei miei preferiti
sono nuovi li ho comprati ieri loro sono
lì possiamo chiamare gatti non è vero e
vero sono più light peak laffi è questa
qua guardate che bella rosellina anche
molto fluffy con i petali quindi andiamo
subito subito a inserirle a questo la
metterei qui la mettiamo qui che è molto
bella quindi riempie un bel buco l'altra
rosellina dove lo mettiamo
dove li qui secondo me che pende bella
bella
un'altra chicca sono queste ballerine
fantastiche sempre frasi che aveva
capito che ci piace quest'anno frasi una
con lo chignon e il tutto bianco e una
contato rosa e i codini il les bains che
anche le altre anche le ali questo non
ne ha a sirena benissimo lei fa la
spaccata guardate che bella e questa
dove la mettiamo
e non lo so qui sopra non è questa
guerra possiamo mettere qui asi intanto
abbiamo anche messo il fiocco di una
pausa abbiamo fatto è stata forse fin
altro così
sila e anche questa è la squadra questa
buona lasciamo giù così secondo esatto
questa è una terza parla finta e poi
abbiamo loro gli omini di pan di zenzero
detti anche e abbiamo la gara abbiamo il
boy e poi abbiamo una casa una mente
house dovranno pur convivere da qualche
parte e quindi andiamo subito a metterli
vediamo dove del nostro numero 1
potrebbe andare subito come crisi così
si vede bene mettiamo lo meno falli
senso qui la casa da vediamo e qui
veniamo dove mettiamo la signorina di
fante kato di pan di zenzero qua
appoggiata qui palla che balla che
carina che suite la casa milà casa la
richiamo la qui sotto la ballerina
cambiati vede in difficoltà dovrebbero
passioni la mettiamo qui allora ci siamo
io lo trovo spettacolare e proprio come
lo volevo con quel tocco di rosa che
rende tutto più marina ma io andrei a
fare un'ulteriore primo piano sui nostri
preferiti
il mio preferito è questo con dentro
guardate che bello
poi la pozione di stata dentro poi
abbiamo il dominio di ginger per il
ginger band è carinissimo che è perché i
titolari ma io amo anche moltissimo la
ballerina che bello
[Musica]
fate finta che sia rapita ma anche il
nostro bocciolo di rosa di rosa
meraviglioso però io oggi ho il mio
preferito è che sono tutti piccoli babbo
natalini barra elfi che non ero l'arma
si parli di perino che dire mariners è
stata un'impresa molto lunga e ci
abbiamo visto un intero pomeriggio ma ne
è valsa la pena questo il mio albero lo
vedrete in tutti i video che girerò da
d'ora in avanti
volevo ringraziare gli assistenti giorgi
detto elfo mariah ha detto andrea vedo
che ci sta riprendendo che è stato
caloroso affetto
oggi mangero ti rivogliamo tra noi
ragazzi visto che avevo iniziato con una
coreografia super
della coreografa marina sulle note di
all our for christmas finiamo con un
canto va alla coreografia improvvisata
proprio così di un'altra canzone natale
cosa possiamo fare
possiamo provare a fare
[Musica]
[Applauso]